Alright everybody, so here is example number one. Looking at GPPUSD on the 6 minute timeframe. So the reason why I'm looking at 6 minute timeframe is because if I go to the 5 minute timeframe, there are two for value gaps here, one here and one here. So remember, as I said before, the leg that takes out liquidity or does a break of structure must only have one fair value gap. And over here, you can see we took out this height here.
Also, this high over here once again.
And let's see if we got something else that we took.
And you can clearly see this old liquidity was taken out.
So now once it was taken out,
we had this fairly up.
We draw this along like that.
And remember, we're gonna trade during the kills on ours.
So from 2am,
right till
1130 now what happens here after liquid sleep and break of structure most of the people would be going long of
This foreverly gap because they would consider this as a break of structure
Right, but this is basically an SMC trap now what happens price closes below this level right here
My entry would be on the retest
Oops, my bad. Right? And first of all, I will adjust my take profit level. So this is right here.
Now it's giving me one to one point zero five. So I can just move it slightly up like that until it
gives me one to one at least. Now this is where I would go break even. And this is the closest
low. Okay, not this because this low was created after the inverse
probability gap was formed. Okay, so this is not going to be your take profit
level because this price section doesn't matter. For your draw on liquidity,
you have to look at the previous price section which was this leg, right? So
So we created in verse, look to the left, which is the closest low, that is going to be a
take profit level.
Now over here, you could have taken full profits or could have gone break even and held
the trade until this level was taken out or even this level was taken out.
So you could have held this would have given you one to one point five or you could have
going for one to two. Very simple and very very powerful. Let's move on to the next example now.